la corte penal internacional abrirá una
investigación en contra de rusia por la
comisión de hechos que puedan ser
considerados como crímenes de guerra
crímenes de lesa humanidad o genocidio
de acuerdo con lo indicado por este
órgano la apertura de esta investigación
se da luego de que 39 estados
presentarán solicitudes para ser
investigados los hechos que pudieran ser
relacionados con este tipo de acciones
de conflicto según lo indicado por el
fiscal karim camps todos los hechos que
puedan ser considerados como crímenes de
guerra y que hayan sido perpetrados
no
[Música]
2013 y la actualidad serán tenidos en
cuenta en el marco de la investigación
como parte de las reacciones que se han
presentado en territorio en irlandés el
primer ministro de países bajos mark
rutte condenó hoy fuertemente que estos
hechos no pueden quedarse en la
impunidad por lo cual a través de una
presentación oficial hecha por el
ministerio de exteriores neerlandés ante
la onu solicitaron el desarrollo de
acciones que permitan el cese de cobo